let's talk about something else many
have written to me about
what the hell happened to the alt-right
where did they go are they still around
at the start of Trump's presidency
everything was alt-right we are the
alt-right they are the alt-right both
self-professed and discussed in media in
policy circles Etc
rarely if ever do we hear about the
alt-right today so what happened to it
did it go the way of the Tea Party
partially destroyed partially integrated
into the modern Republican party has
Maga trumpism essentially absorbed the
alt-right well let's talk about it in
the early 2010s as the Tea Party had
gotten their wins and then started to
fade that happened in 2010 so then you
go to 2013 2014. this new political
movement emerged in the United States
which was ultimately known as the
alt-right
Loosely defined group of individuals
rejected mainstream conservatism dabbled
in white nationalism dabbled in
anti-Semitism dabbled in uh xenophobia
and all sorts of other far-right
ideologies and as the 2016 presidential
election got going and Donald Trump
ultimately won the nomination of the
Republican party and became a general
election candidate and won 2015
2016-2017 we saw the alt-right gain
significant prominence
since then though the alt-right as such
has significantly faded out of public
eye why did this happen there's a number
of things that are going on important to
identify to understand the continued
evolution of Mega trumpism number one
the alt-right as such started to get hit
with significant backlash from media
from the left and from mainstream
conservatives as well people like Mitt
Romney kinzinger Etc who distanced
themselves from the movement and
condemned its extremist views they saw
that under trumpism it was continuing to
grow and that it wasn't a good thing as
far as they were concerned secondly many
of the alt-right leaders ended up
exposed they were exposed as really just
being racist really just being
anti-semitic really just being
xenophobic and so many of the alt-right
leaders lost credibility and they lost
support and some of them ended up kind
of dissolving into Mega trumpism
uh third we saw Maga trumpism
accept and absorb
some elements of alt-right ideology
certainly the cultish loyalty to Donald
Trump the rejection of establishment
politics embracing populist rhetoric
which you then fill in with right-wing
policy prescriptions when it comes to it
and so magatrumpism I mean listen I'm
trying to be fair and charitable here
there are of course elements of
anti-Semitism and white nationalism and
mega trumpism without a doubt I don't
believe Trump created them but he
coalesced them and he welcomed them in
the mega trumpism what I'm trying to be
accurate but also not weak in it Mega
trumpism was less overtly anti-semitic
and homophobic and whatever else the
case may be than the alt-right and thus
has achieved some success by kind of
integrating some of those alt-right
elements into it one big difference
between the alt-right and mega trumpism
is that Mega trumpism has succeeded in
part because they have this charismatic
to some degree cult-like leader in Trump
whereas the alt-right never really had
that leader they had a bunch of
different people who led different
aspects of it Richard Spencer maybe
Gavin McGinnis and I know I'm forgetting
a bunch of others but they didn't have
Trump and so Trump's presence was a big
factor in mega trumpism superseding the
alt-right so bottom line the alt-right
as such has indeed greatly faded from
public View
its views haven't gone away and it has a
legacy inside of Mega trumpism the
question we are now left with is will it
survive another election cycle or will
the boberts and the Marjorie Taylor
greens and Trump himself
suffer a 2024 defeat that could be the
final nail in the coffin for this
roughly decade period is what it will be
at the end of the day eight years ten
years roughly 11 years depending on when
you consider the start of alt-right will
alt-right die
as part of Mega trumpism in 2024 that's
the question that remains to be answered
and one we're going to continue asking
we'll take a quick break make sure you
are subscribed to the YouTube channel at
youtube.com the davidpackman show
pushing very strongly towards two
million subscribers
one of our sponsors is electric e-bikes
I've been watching e-bike reviews on
YouTube for a while because I've been
thinking of getting one and I
continually come across electric as the
brand to go with if your budget is
between 800 and 1300 and I have to agree
from experience I've had my electric
e-bike for a little while now I've
almost ditched my car and regularly bike
at this point for errands and things
around my neighborhood it's awesome
cardio because I'm still pedaling I get
there faster I can see more I'm reducing
my carbon footprint the e-bike came to
my doorstep fully assembled it has a
bright LCD screen seven speed gearing
five levels of pedal assist a powerful
battery that you can take inside to
charge it's also fully foldable I can
put it in the back of my car electric
has models for every lifestyle and you
can Finance for as little as 73 bucks a
month go to electricebikes.com to learn
more explore all of the incredible
e-bike models they offer the link is
down below